after the game because you know tyron
taylor got
scratched injury and warm-ups we're like
who gets hurt in warm-ups who has a
chest and dream warm-up so it's weird to
begin with
justin herbert has a great out and we're
like okay well that's it you know they
drafted him six overall
he's a quarterback then anthony delaney
comes out and he's like well
if tyra is healthy he's our starter we
like bro why
you know what i mean okay here's why so
he had crack ribs
took a pain killing injection before the
game the team doctor
accidentally punctured his long
man and so now come on justin herbert
remains a starter listen mike
wow it's funny and it's oddly enough 19
years ago today you know what happened
19 years ago today
brady replaced bledsoe brady replaced
bledsoe
all right so i believe that you can lose
your job to injury
people say you can't lose your injury i
believe you can't you can yeah you can
in this case what do you do if you're
the chargers i know what you do if
you're tyrod taylor you file a grievance
and georgia tyler from the nfl plays
association already hinted to as much
on twitter saying oh yeah we've been in
touch with the agent and the team
since sunday so he's got a nice
grievance coming because what do you do
with the other chargers
if you stick with justin herbert
and you're tyrell taylor you're like
hold up hold up for a second yeah
eventually i was gonna have to pass the
job i was like the pastor takes my job
away from me you took my job
from me and compromised my livelihood
because of your incompetence
yeah this is it's really an unbelievable
story and there's already uh mike
uh and here's a tweet here from george
friend of the show uh georgia tala our
medical and legal team have been in
touch with tyrod and his agent since
sunday collecting facts an investigation
has been initiated look there's already
a fragile relationship
between team doctors and players
now listen it's the medical profession
so you you respect them for having
a knowledge base that you don't have
you're a player most players don't have
that
but on the other hand they are working
for the team and so in judgment calls
you're always a little
skeptical are you saying this because
it's best for me
or is it best for the team and that's
why uh every
every member of the union every member
of the nfl pa has the right to get a
second opinion
or a third opinion away from that team
doctor but this is why
that that that tension exists i mean
this is an
extreme example but it's always in the
back of your mind
why is this happening why are they
telling me to play i feel like there's
something going on
going on with my knee going over my
elbow they're telling me i can play
without aggravating it
aggravating it is that correct
information
and if i do get that second opinion will
that be held against me
even though that's my right so there's a
lot going on here
uh i think tyrod taylor i feel sorry for
toronto
yeah he's he's going to wind up with
some money
i think he is well but well it should
because it's costing him money he could
potentially get from another team and
he's you know
underappreciated and i know he has his
flaws but
was the last good pop was the last good
quarterback that buffalo had before josh
allen obviously and he's playing really
well but
you know took that team to the playoffs
but wasn't valued in buffalo
now and we know in cleveland he gave way
rather quickly to baker mayfield
again number one overall pick that's how
that's how it goes you know and in this
case we know it was keeping
the seat one from justin herbert but man
to see him
go down like this if i'm anthony lynn i
almost feel like
i gotta put him back in no matter how
well herbert plays but you can't do that
man
you can't do that though you can't do
that you can't
between a rod he's between a rock and a
hard place what you're saying yeah i
mean you can't do that you can't put
them back in
just because your your team doctor
screwed up and
now you're making it he did something
wrong it provided an opportunity for
herbert who was going to get the job i
mean they drafted the guy sixth overall
so it was only a matter of time i know
but but you but you
know you thought torreira gave you the
best chance to win coming in this season
it looks like herbert looked better in
week two than toronto looking week one i
get it sure but if you're anthony lynn
we're talking about team and we're
together and commitment
it's not his fault anthony lyndon
administered a pain killing shot but
how do you how do you just say torah hey
sorry man them the breaks
you know how do you do that that's just
you can't hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports